bonsoir ce que le réseau théorie go
merci d'être avec nous ces violences
pour vous était elle prévisible
oui bon ça la toussaint même si pour
l'invitation et bat en effet en khl à
nier qu'ils pourraient dégénérer les
violences at-elle comment nous avons vu
d'après l'émission que vous venez de
passer
et même si la pression de la vue et par
la pression le gouvernement a dû retirer
cette réforme fiscale et le ministre a
dû démissionner les mécontentements des
citoyens est si fort que les
manifestants et les manifestations se
révèle de plus en plus nombreuses dans
tous les coins du pays et cela malgré la
forte pression du gouvernement les
chiffres des violations des droits de
l'homme sont est scandaleuse nous
comptons aujourd'hui 31 ans ni side des
jeunes qui manifestaient pacifiquement
et blue après 89 gens portés disparus
presque un milliard d'arrestations
arbitraires 21 victimes d'attaqués
oculaire est à peu près 77,4 des coups
d'armé à feu et des victimes des
violences sexuelles et sans compter et
tous les arrestations et arbitraire qui
se contentent dans tous les pays et nous
vivons ces moments des moments de grande
tension dont la jud la journée et de
nuit véritable horreur et les présidents
a décidé la militarisation du pays
pendant les dernières jours nous
assistons à des scènes d'horreur en
direct à travers les réseaux sociaux
nous savons la presle impression qu et
notamment pendant la nuit c'est sur les
militaires qui commande dans le pays et
que les maires et les gouverneurs
régionaux et non ce ne sont pas entendus
par le gouvernement deux ans et
s'appelle est d'arrêter la violence la
brutalité contre les manifestants
comment vous vous expliquer c'est
violent c'est vrai qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir un pays comme
la colombie avec ces images choquantes
comment les expliquer la vérité la
vérité c'est que les gens sont vraiment
et puis c'est avec un gouvernement qui a
pas donné des garanties face à la
pandémie
les gens sont en train d'écrire défend
la réforme fiscale qui ont essayé de
passer et a affecté et porter notamment
contre la classe moyenne et les secteurs
les plus vulnérables et qui ces voix
sont garanties de la part du
gouvernement alors que et les banques et
les gants et vêtements public à qui ça
fait pendant la halle et à l'émergence
est inversée levé course pour sauver la
banque a publié pour le secteur et plus
favorisés et la la la la la crise aussi
grave que les gens non plus n'en peut
plus et peur de la pandémie et de risque
de contagion est alors que en traversant
les pics dans les 3e balle de la plus
fort de la pandémie en ce moment est à
peu près de 500 morts par jour et nuit à
moi les gens n'ont plus peur de perdre
leur vie n'ont plus peur de faire face à
la brutalité de l'état et les forces
militaires et forces de l'ordre puisque
puisqu'elles sont vraiment est
inacceptable et les mesures qui sont
prises par les gouvernements en ce
moment et la brutalité inco et la
répression
initialement ces manifestations c'était
contre le projet de réforme fiscale qui
a pourtant été retiré depuis ça veut
dire que dans france n'était qu'un
simple prétexte le malaise et est bien
plus profond lehmann s il est bien plus
profond et ce n'est pas seulement contre
ces réformes a qu'une protection
colombie mais aussi contre une réforme
des contrats et pour la santé qui est en
train de céder ses maîtres de cette
consultation du parlement qui est
complément est contraire aux intérêts
des travailleurs de la santé et des
citoyens et ses réformes et cette
prothèse cette manifestation se font
aussi contre un gouvernement et qui a
démontré son incapacité pour qu'elle
soit pour faire face à la crise qu'ils
ne devaient pas la pandémie un
gouvernement qui a des graves
après les graves accusations par
corruption par violations des droits de
l'homme et un gouvernement qui ne
respecte pas les accords qui ont été
signés avec la guérilla et l'as far et
avec les compromis qui ont été acquis
près de la communauté internationale un
gouvernement qui ne fait rien pour
arrêter l'assassinât des leaders sociaux
et l'assassinât des gens qui se sont
démobilisés et donc il est un véritable
de clis et en colombie une explosion
sociale et à un moment qu'il n'avait pas
vécu dans les dernières sont sentent en
colombie et on craint surtout et c'est
que sous prétexte de la tension sociale
et des de la crise que nous vivons et
les gouvernements et va passer un état
de marges en ca supérieur qui va
permettre éventuellement même d'empêcher
les sélections est envisagé pour l'année
prochaine pour 2021 2022
donc on est essentielle à lille à
nouveau président de la république a et
un congrès la république
on est face à un gouvernement qui jouit
d'une popularité des mois de 33% et les
anglais les dernières sondages et
démontre que si la sélection se fera
aujourd'hui est celui qui fait la
position en colombie sceller les
présidents qu'ont ces moments et on
craint vraiment que c'est tout ça c'est
un il ya un intérêt de la part des
gouvernements mais aussi des deux
groupes à un hommage de la loi et pour
empêcher un changement dans le pays pour
empêcher des sélections qui permettre en
virement dans un gouvernement plus
garantie pour les citoyens
vous parliez des facs ce sera ma
dernière question justement le
gouvernement a argué que des dissidents
à des farc
ainsi que l'armée de libération
nationale dernière en rébellion du pays
on le précise et des gants garde de
narcotrafiquants orchestré ces troubles
ce sont des faits avérés
à vrai dire elle la plupart des
manifestations sont pacifiques
mais il est vrai que les médias et le
gouvernement colombien essaye de
démontrer et d'éclaircies panique dans
le sens où on est dépassé par des
violences et qui ne sait pas
ils viennent parce que dans les
manifestations il apparaît on a les
informations qu'il a des centres et des
deux groupes à marche de la loi et
qu'ils ont intérêt à faire ces climats
des paniques de glisse mais mais mais
surtout et il faudra marquer que dans la
plupart des miliaires des citoyens et
des colombiens que ces manifestants
pacifiques pacifiquement dans la rue et
c'est tout la force de l'ordre qui est
des manières d proportionnée et
utilisées pendant l'ère pendant la
journée et aussi dans la nuit qui était
inacceptable et il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas de il n'a pas d'équivalence il n'y a
pas de proportionnalité entre
l'utilisation de la force de l'ordre
public et le désordre qui qui qui qui se
mène en parcelles pas un coin et dont
certains 7 euros minoritaire si vous
voulez et on a peut vraiment que dans
cette confusion est celui qui sait
favorise a finalement c'est le
gouvernement qui essaye d d d installer
et ce discours de la de l'ennemi interne
et pour moi à travers celui là et
permettre de passer à un état de
concentration des pouvoirs et un et à
l'émergence la plus grave qui va arrêter
va suspendre encore plus les garanties
démocratiques d'un état de droit
merci c'est le racing et origo d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france